le chef d'État le plus scruté du monde
donne dans quelques minutes un discours
que toute la planète écoutera d'une
oreille très attentive Vladimir Poutine
prend la parole dans quelques minutes
pour s'adresser à sa nation c'est un
rendez-vous traditionnel qui est lieu
tous les ans mais à 3 jours du premier
anniversaire de l'invasion de l'Ukraine
par les Russes c'est une allocution
retentissement internationale que nous
allons suivre ensemble bonjour Fabrice
nodelungois bonjour Thibault merci
d'être ici à Dakar en chef du service
économie du Figaro et surtout ancien
correspondant du journal à Moscou
Fabrice ce discours à la nation vous qui
avez connu ça j'imagine tous les ans
lorsque vous étiez correspondant là-bas
c'est un moment important en Russie oui
c'est un des grands rendez-vous de du
président Poutine avec la nation il y a
un autre rendez-vous qui est très suivi
où il s'adresse directement au peuple où
il va il y a des duplex avec des gens
dans toute la Russie qui est très suivi
et celui-ci le discours
devant les deux chambres il y a le
système
il y a les à la fois la Douma la chambre
basse et le Conseil de la fédération qui
est si vous voulez l'équivalent du Sénat
alors évidemment depuis plus de 20 ans
que Vladimir Poutine et est au pouvoir
ce Parlement n'est même pas une chambre
d'enregistrement quand on parle parfois
même en France avec mépris de députés
godillot là là c'est le cas mais malgré
tout il y a une dimension symbolique il
rassemble donc les parlementaires des
deux chambres dans dans gasty de vol qui
est un
direct centre de Moscou donc on n'est
pas au Kremlin on est tout près du
Kremlin mais c'est en dehors du Kremlin
ou effectivement déjà plusieurs reprises
c'est ici que que ce discours a été
prononcé donc il y a les parlementaires
et puis aussi certainement des invités
de marque et à ton dit beaucoup de
militaires c'est évidemment un symbole
très fort alors que le premier
anniversaire de l'invasion de l'Ukraine
sera marqué d'ici trois jours
dans dans ce discours à la nation alors
c'est clairement un discours avant tout
à usage interne voilà où le président
peut annoncer un certain nombre
d'orientation sur sa politique
économique sur sa politique tout court
donc orientation
à destination de du public russe avant
tout là évidemment il y aura une
résonance très particulière vu les
circonstances et puis vu les
circonstances parce que la veille Joe
Biden lui a donné le pion en se rendant
par surprise à Kiev Joe Biden qui
prononce en plus un discours également à
Varsovie tout à l'heure donc certains
experts en fait parallèle un peu avec la
guerre froide alors faut faire toujours
un peu attention en parallèle historique
mais il y a quand même un peu un écho un
relent de guerre froide dans dans ces
doubles discours d'un côté le président
américain qui est allé soutenir avec un
symbole très très fort
Kiev l'Ukraine maintenant attaqué depuis
un an et puis Poutine qui s'adresse à sa
nation le discours va commencer à midi
selon Moscou voilà ce que nous devient
l'internaute oui
française pas toujours ensemble de se
retrouver Fabrice tiens je lis
d'ailleurs la première question j'en
profite je rebondis sur ce que vous
étiez en train de me dire quelles
conséquences de la pseudo surprise de
Biden en Ukraine est-ce qu'il est-ce que
ce qu'il s'est passé hier une visite non
prévue de Joe Biden à Kiev peut changer
la tonalité du discours de Vladimir
Poutine aujourd'hui alors non prévu mais
une petite remarque au passage vous
savez que les Américains ont averti
quelques heures avant les autorités
russes pour des raisons de sécurité en
même temps avertir au turque si jamais
il y avait eu des tirs de missiles
un peu trop proche du passage du
président la Russie n'aurait pas pu
prétendre qu'elle n'était pas informé de
l'avenue du président donc il y a des
canaux quand même de
de
discussion on ne sait pas forcément très
bien lesquels mais les Russes avaient
été avertis alors plutôt une bonne
nouvelle d'une certaine manière que les
états majors puissent communiquer entre
eux continuent à se parler je dirais pas
de telles conséquences personnellement
en revanche évidemment le la venue de
Joe Biden à Kiev quelque part apporte de
l'eau au moulin de Vladimir Poutine
parce que ça peut encore plus renforcer
son discours sur le thème nous sommes
attaqués par l'OTAN par l'Occident
regardez Biden soutien ce régime de
néo-nazi dont nous voulons vous
débarrasser donc à limite ça ne peut que
conforter un discours qu'on attend
plutôt
belliqueux et très ferme à ces images
avec ces deux hommes favoris ce modèle
en gloire de personnes
avec des lunettes et le chef d'État le
ministre de l'Administration
de Vladimir Poutine on dit souvent un
peu par raccourci un tel est très proche
de l'univers Poutine shoegou fait
vraiment partie
au début vers le début de la guerre il y
avait eu effectivement une une
disparition un peu mystérieuse faut
toujours très prudent sur les
conséquences parce qu'on ne sait pas
grand-chose il faut être humble il a été
réapparu il semble toujours faire partie
vraiment du premier cercle discours dans
le ghost in ITV
alors c'est une sorte de palais des
congrès je suis allé chercher sur
internet c'est des Halles
il y a des différents événements cadre
toujours spectaculaire je sens qu'on
avait fait un discours ensemble lors de
l'annonce de Zen de l'annexion de
certains territoires ça c'est très
important pour Vladimir Poutine de
montrer
une force une puissance par les images
oui si ce n'est que c'est c'est un
discours on le voit sur les images un
décor pardon qui se veut plus moderne
c'est plus télévisuel que les ors du
Kremlin de cette Saint-Georges ou
effectivement il avait français très
solennellement l'annexion des quatre
régions
ukrainiennes alors il ne faut pas
oublier aussi que demain Vladimir
Poutine va apparaître dans un stade le
stade loginiqui à Moscou ou là c'est il
veut donner aussi un symbole très très
fort
les médias russes parlent de 200000
personnes qui seraient rassemblées dans
ce stade pour montrer faire une
démonstration de force montrer que le
peuple derrière lui appuie tout à fait
l'opération spéciale comme il appelle
cette guerre qui dure maintenant depuis
un an 9h58 nous sommes en direct pour
suivre le discours de Vladimir Poutine
le président russe s'adresse à sa nation
presque un an après le début de
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par par les
Russes
venons-en au discours il va
s'adresser à son peuple comme le veut la
tradition ou est-ce que non là il va
clairement parler à la communauté
internationale il y a forcément les deux
mon colonel avant tout ce discours
s'adresse vraiment au peuple russe mais
bien sûr puisque il est scruté dans le
monde entier il y aura des messages
forts vis-à-vis de la communauté
internationale
vis-à-vis de l'Ukraine vis-à-vis de des
États-Unis encore une fois moi je
m'attends mais il faut être prudent
parce qu'il y a beaucoup moins de fuite
en Russie sur avant un discours que que
dans notre pays par exemple
je m'attends à ce que Vladimir Poutine
est un discours quand même toujours très
très dur
sur voilà c'est Occident qui se ligue
contre la Russie et la Russie qui défend
finalement qui défend presque son
existence cette opposition il a
peut-être besoin de montrer aussi à son
peuple
qu'il n'a pas la tête qu'on Ukraine qui
s'occupe de leur préoccupations bien sûr
je pense qu'il aura à cœur de montrer
que l'économie russe résiste puisque au
printemps dernier nombre d'experts
internationaux y compris le FMI ils
s'attendait à une contraction de
l'économie russe de près de 10% on a
parlé de 8%, et finalement d'après les
chiffres du même FMI l'économie russe
c'est certes contracté en 2022 mais
seulement de 2% et le FMI ça t'emmène à
une légère croissance en 2023 alors là
les experts sont très partagés tout
dépendra de l'effet de l'embargo sur le
pétrole russe et voilà je crois que le
discours va démarrer Thibault
nous allons voir ce journée on entendra
donc Vladimir Poutine on va suivre
l'arrivée du président russe avec ce
parterre beaucoup d'hommes toujours
Fabrice et alors j'ai l'impression que
c'est bien le patriarche Kyril qui est
au premier rang à côté de Dimitri
Medvedev l'ancien président russe qui
fut aussi le premier ministre de
Vladimir Poutine et devenu
une de ces voix les plus radicales ce
qui était extrêmement
souple c'est pas libéral à une époque il
a été président on parlait d'un
modernisateur d'un libéral et il est
devenu vraiment des porte-voix les plus
radicaux les plus extrémistes du régime
quelque part ils jouent sa survie il
sait qu'il n'a plus de d'issue en dehors
de ce régime et autant le soutenir
jusqu'au bout comme un certain nombre
d'autres
membres du Cercle du premier cercle
Vladimir Poutine
à Moscou rédacteur en chef du Figaro
économie je vous ai lu ce matin j'ai lu
l'interview vous vous faisiez de béata
j'avortique
de la banque européenne de développement
la perde alors certains donc eux ils
tapent vous me dites que le FMI table
sur une croissance de 0,3 % pour la
Russie la berbe tape plutôt sur une
contractions alors évidemment ils sont à
cette économiste prudente en disant que
ça dépend de de beaucoup de choses
notamment de l'effet effectivement
encore l'embargo et le prix plafond sur
les exportations de pétrole russe
sachant que ces sanctions ces embargos
ne sont pas pris par le monde entier
parce qu'on peut appeler l'Occident et
que certains nombre de pays comme la
Chine comme l'Inde continue d'acheter
massivement des hydrocarbures russes et
même si le pétrole russe se vend plutôt
moins cher par rapport pétrole de
référence le pétrole Brent ça fait
encore des rentrées très importantes
dans les caisses de l'Etat russe pour
financer la guerre est-ce que les Russes
souffrent de ces sanctions occidentales
est-ce que la vie a vraiment changé en
Russie alors si on répond brièvement on
pourrait dire non pas fondamentalement
c'est ce que nous raconte Alain Barlet
notre notre correspondant en tout cas à
Moscou maintenant ça et là il y a des
pénuries des choses qui sont de plus en
plus compliquées alors Alain Alain
barlues des exemples qui sont parfois
presque cocasses il y avait des boyaux
utilisés pour pour fabriquer des
saucisses des saucissons qui venaient
d'usine européenne et par moments ces
boyaux ont manqué après les Russes
savent aussi fabriquer se mettent à
fabriquer un certain nombre de choses
dans l'automobile qui est un des
secteurs peut-être les plus touchés
parce que l'automobile automobile
bien sûr Lada était qui était
filiale du groupe Renault
construit toujours des voitures bien sûr
une marque très populaire avec des
modèles modernes
cependant l'industrie russe
souffert du manque de composants
notamment des puces électroniques le
monde entier et Alain Barlet nous
raconte par exemple que en ce moment
certains modèles de la dalle à la Niva
travel pour être précis n'a plus que une
couleur verte il n'y a que la peinture
verte qui est disponible parce que tous
les approvisionnements même si par
exemple la peinture ne fait pas l'objet
de sanction tous les approvisionnements
sont compliqués parce que les
transactions financières entre
l'Occident et la Russie sont compliqués
donc il y a des circuits commerciaux qui
sont de plus en plus complexes qui
passent par des pays tiers comme le
Kazakhstan la Turquie l'Arménie donc ça
rallonge les délais de livraison ça
renchérit les coûts mais malgré tout
l'économie russe s'en sort plutôt bien
ils ont l'art de la débrouille les
Russes ils ont connu d'autres périodes
très difficiles et donc vikevail pour
l'instant l'économie russe résiste parce
qu'elle avait des finances solides avant
d'aborder cette guerre mais on sait que
les sanctions si elles perdure auront
des effets plutôt sur le long terme
est-ce que le rouble la valeur du rouble
étanche chute libre est-ce qu'il
s'effondre non non le rouble résiste
alors il avait plongé très brutalement
juste au début de la guerre mais après
la banque centrale la soutenue alors
c'est un peu artificiel parce qu'il y a
moins de transactions moins d'échange
mais globalement le Groupe a plutôt bien
résisté donc c'est aussi c'est un
symbole fort et tout dit n'en parlera
peut-être dans son discours le rouble a
globalement plutôt résisté ce qui est
plutôt bien pour quand on importe des
produits le chef de l'État russe
Vladimir Poutine le président russe
s'adresse dans quelques instants à sa
nation et pas que vous l'avez bien
compris ce sera un discours probablement
avec une portée internationale les
images donc dans ce gosse
ce palais des congrès de Pauline
triés sur le volant en imagine de ce
discours se lève pour applaudir le
Président russe merci Fabrice on suit le
discours très attendu de Vladimir
Poutine alors que nous fêtons dans trois
jours nous célébrons malheureusement
dans trois jours le début de la guerre
en Ukraine
de la Fédération
mesdames et messieurs débutez de la
Douma dans mon discours d'aujourd'hui
je m'adresse à vous dans un temps
difficile
c'est en temps très important quand il
se passe des changements partout dans le
monde ce sont des événements historiques
qui vont définir l'avenir de notre pays
de notre peuple
chacun de nous porte une responsabilité
colossale il y a un an pour protéger
les gens sur nos terres historiques et
pour protéger la sécurité de notre pays
pour contrer la menace qui venait d'un
régime néonazi après le coup d'État de
1914 nous avons pris la décision de
mener l'opération militaire spéciale et
pas à pas de manière très conséquente
nous allons résoudre les problèmes qui
se posent devant nous depuis 2014
le don basse a combattu pour protéger
son droit de vivre sur sa terre natale
et parler sa langue maternelle le gambas
à lutter dans des conditions de bolocus
sous les tirs et malgré la haine du
régime de Kiev le donc basse croyait que
la Russie allait venir à son secours
[Applaudissements]
cependant et vous le savez très bien
nous avons fait tout ce qui était
possible pour résoudre ce problème par
des moyens pacifiques de manière très
patiente nous avons mené des discussions
et des négociations pour sortir de ce
conflit cependant derrière notre dos on
préparait un autre scénario et les
dirigeants occidentaux qui n'ont fait
des promesses qui ont parlé de la paix
en réalité était en mensonge cruel il
les essayer de gagner du temps c'était
de la bureaucratie il fermait les yeux
sur des assassinats politiques sur les
répressions du régime de Kiev contre
ceux qui n'aimaient pas sur des
exactions contre les croyants les
actions terroristes dans le don basse
occidentales ont formé des bataillons
nationalistes ont livré des armements et
je voudrais souligner que avant le début
de l'opération militaire spécial qui ifs
déjà à négocier les livraisons d'armes
notamment d'armure et des avions de
combat nous avons vu tous ces efforts de
régime de keyev nous savions aussi
obtenir l'harmonie nucléaire l'OTAN et
les États-Unis
ont déployé des bases militaires et des
laboratoires biologiques secrets
pour se préparer
à ses combats pour
préparer ces Ukraine soumise à ces
combats et en fait aujourd'hui il
l'avoue publiquement
on dirait qu'ils en sont fiers quand ils
parlent des accords de mince du format
de Normandie ils disent que c'était un
spectacle diplomatique c'était du bluff
c'est pendant quand on basse était en
feu quand le sang était versé et pendant
que la Russie de manière très sincère je
le souligne souligne inspiré à la paix
eux ils jouaient avec la vie des gens en
utilisant
en jeu de
cartes faussées
[Musique]
et ils ont toujours été aussi hypocrites
dans le cas de la Yougoslavie l'Irak la
Libye c'était une honte ils vont jamais
pouvoir laver de honte et en ce qui
concerne la confiance
l'honnêteté
il ne connaissent pas ce que c'est
l'empirialisme c'est l'hégémonie il
pense que tout leur est permis ils sont
habitués à cela et apparemment ils ont
la même attitude envers leurs propres
peuple ils ont trompé leur peuple de
manière aussi chimique de rencontrer des
fables ils ont dit que ils allaient
exécuter les résolutions du Conseil de
l'Union sur le don-basse mais en fait ce
sont des mensonges sans aucun principe
nous nous défendons nos intérêts de
manière ferme et notre position que dans
le monde moderne on ne doit pas partager
les pays en pays civilisés et autre pays
il faut avoir en partenariat honnête qui
ne prévoit pas d'exclusivité pour
certains pays surtout quand ce sont des
pays agressifs nous sommes prêts à un
dialogue ouvert et sincère avec
l'oxydant nous avons toujours
un système que l'Europe et la Russie ont
besoin d'un système équitable de
sécurité et nous avons pendant des
années proposées cette idée pour
travailler sur la mise en oeuvre de
cette idée mais nous avons reçu
une des réactions hypocrites ça en ce
qui concerne les paroles et puis nous
avons vu des actes aussi c'est
l'élargissement de l'OTAN ce sont des
régions dans lesquelles on installé de
système de défense anti-missiles comme
un parapluie c'est le développement des
troupes également le long des frontières
de la Russie mais pas seulement je
voudrais souligner tout le monde le sait
aucun pays dans le monde n'a autant de
base militaires que les États-Unis dans
d'autres pays du monde il y en a des
centaines je le souligne dans le monde
entier c'est-à-dire toute la planète est
couverte de ces bases
le monde entier a été témoin comment les
États-Unis ont quitté les accords très
importants y compris l'accord est fini
de manière unilatérale et ils ont
ils sont sortis de différents accords
très importants pour la sécurité mais
pourquoi ils l'ont fait c'est pas par
hasard et enfin en décembre 2021 nous
avons envoyé officiellement aux
États-Unis et à l'OTAN notre proposition
des accords sur les garanties de
sécurité mais pour tous les points qui
étaient les plus importants pour nous
nous avons reçu en reçu direct et à ce
moment-là nous avons compris de manière
définitive
ils avaient déjà donné le feu vert pour
la réalisation de leur plan et la mena
c'était en augmentation de jour en jour
et en février
2022 tout était prêt pour mener des
actions pimitives dans les dons basses
je vous rappelle en 2014 déjà le régime
de Kiev a déjà employé l'artillerie les
avions les chars contre le don-basse
contre cv-rodoniens ce que nous nous
souvenons deux images pas seulement
c'est leur donner ce que mais d'autres
villes en 2015 ils ont à nouveau essayé
d'attaquer directement le donbasse tout
en continuant le blocus et les tirs
contre les civils je vous rappelle tout
cela est allé à l'encontre des
résolutions qui ont été à adapter
par le conseil de l'ONU
tout le monde faisait comme si de rien
n'était je voudrais le répéter c'est eux
qui ont déclenché cette guerre et nous
nous avons
utilisé la force pour arrêter cette
guerre
planifié une nouvelle attaque contre le
Denis est-ce que le Logan comprenait
très bien que l'objectif suivant c'est
une frappe contre la Crimée et
Sébastopol
nous avons compris il y avait ces plans
et maintenant accueillez vous n'en parle
ouvertement ils ont avoué tout ce qu'on
savait déjà nous protégeons les vies des
gens notre propre maison l'objectif des
de l'Occident c'est le pouvoir sans son
compte milliards de dollars ont déjà été
déployés pour aider ce régime
les pays du G7 en 2020-2021 ont versé 60
milliards pour aider les pays pauvres
ont développé ils ont un verset 550
milliards pour la guerre et 60 au pays
les plus pauvres dont il parle tant
et c'est pays
le support de ces pays les plus pauvres
c'est ça le rude contre la pauvreté et
cependant l'argent ou la flou pour se
tenir la guerre et également il
soutiennent les différents ou des tas
dans les différents pays de monde à la
conférence de Munich que nous avons
encore une fois entendu
des reproches à la Russie des
accusations c'est comme si tout le monde
avait oublié tout ce que l'Occident
avait fait depuis les dernières dizaines
d'années c'est eux qui ont laissé le
jean sortir de la bouteille
je voudrais rappeler toutes les guerres
c'est pas nous qui avons inventé ces
chiffres c'est les Américains qui
publient les chiffres concernant les
guerres que les
États Unis ont déclenché
il y a eu
des centaines des 900 000 morts dans ces
différentes guerres déclenchées par les
États-Unis mais eux ils font comme si
rien ne s'était passé mais personne dans
le monde ne l'a oublié
personne ne compte les tragédies
humaines les pertes de vie parce que
l'objectif ce sont des trillions et les
mots sur la démocratie et la liberté ce
ne sont que des mots en fait l'objectif
c'est de soumettre les pays c'est de
insulter les leaders se décrire l'image
de l'ennemi pour essayer de
d'orienter l'attention des gens ailleurs
pour que les gens ne pensent pas aux
problèmes intérieurs un problème interne
sociaux au problème
ethniques dans ces pays je voudrais
également
l'Occident a agi déjà qu'est-ce qu'il a
fait avec l'Allemagne et ensuite ce
qu'il a fait de l'Ukraine et ceux qui
connaissent l'histoire connaisse ce
projet qui a commencé au 19e siècle déjà
l'Empire austro-hongrois la Pologne et
d'autres pays ont commencé ce projet le
but était unique c'est-à-dire arracher
les territoires historiques qui sont
appelés aujourd'hui l'Ukraine les
arracher à notre pays il n'y a rien de
nouveau
tout se répète
un l'Occident
a augmenté la cadence de ce projet
aujourd'hui en soutenant le coup d'État
de 2014 c'était un coup en quantité
anticonstitutionnel mais c'est comme si
de rien n'était on a même dit combien
d'argent l'Occident a employé
en nationalisme agressif dans une des
brigade des forces armées de l'Ukraine
c'est honteux a reçu le nom Edelweiss
c'est exactement comme une division de
Hitler qui est participé à la
déportation des Juifs à des opérations
punitives à des fusillés
en tchécoslavie en Italie et d'autres
pays et là
dans la garde nationale de l'Ukraine on
voit également les insignes avec la tête
de mort et d'autres chevrons et ce sont
des signes connaissons déjà comme les
signes de l'Allemagne nazie de l'armée
de Wehrmacht
ne cache pas qu'ils sont les héritiers
de tout cela et c'est étonnant que en
Occident
les hauts responsables ne remarquent
rien de tout ça pourquoi parce qu'ils
sont fichent je vous demande pardon pour
l'expression de tout cela ils veulent
utiliser tous les moyens pour lutter
contre la Russie le plus important c'est
de faire la guerre contre la Russie donc
il faut utiliser tous les terroristes
des néonaties le diable lui-même
pourrait être utilisé pour
utiliser tout cela comme arme contre la
Russie
c'est une politique de revenus contre
notre pays pour créer des
foyers dans stabilité contre notre pays
dans les années 30 du siècle dernier et
aujourd'hui il y a une seule intention
d'amener l'agression
à l'est c'est à dire faire une guerre
par procuration en Europe nous ne
faisons pas la guerre contre le peuple
ukrainien parce que le peuple
ukrainien est en réalité l'otage du
régime de hier et des maîtres
occidentaux de ce régime qui ont
occupé ce pays en thermopolitique
économique et militaire pendant des
dizaines d'années ils ont payé les
richesses nationales
ukrainiennes ils ont détruit l'industrie
la conduit à une augmentation de la
pauvreté de des inégalités et c'était
facile dans ces conditions d'avoir
un terrain propice pour déclencher
ce conflit on ne pensait pas aux gens où
les utilisent c'est très triste
la responsabilité de ce conflit
ukrainien de l'escalade d'augmentation
des victimes cette responsabilité est
sur les épaules des Occidentaux et du
régime de qui ce régime ne sert pas les
intérêts nationaux mais les intérêts des
pays tiers l'Occident utilisent
l'Ukraine comme une plateforme et comme
un butoir contre la Russie et je ne
parle pas en détail des plans
d'augmentation de livraison d'armes à
l'Ukraine mais je voudrais cependant
citer une circonstance
plus on livre d'armes à longue portée à
l'Ukraine au plus on sera obligé de
venir pour repousser cette menace contre
notre pays
[Applaudissements]
occidentales ne cache pas leurs
objectifs portés à leur Russie en coups
et je cite
un couche stratégique en échec
stratégique à la Russie cela veut dire
quoi pour nous ça veut dire nous
détruire pour toujours et il voudrait
que le conflit local devienne une
confrontation globale
c'est ainsi qu'on le comprend et
on va réagir bien sûr
de la manière qui convient parce que
dans ce cas là c'est l'existence même de
notre pays sera menacé mais ils doivent
comprendre qu'il n'est pas possible de
gagner la bataille contre la Russie sur
le terrain c'est pour cela que il
font des attaques en formationnels
contre nous il s'appuie sur des jeunes
générations de plus en plus
il se sont encore des mensonges et
travestissent l'histoire il n'arrête pas
d'attaquer notre culture l'Église
orthodoxe russe et autres associations
organisations religieuse regardez ce
qu'ils font à leur propre peuple ils
détruisent la famille l'identité
culturelle ethnique
regardez ce qu'ils font aux enfants la
pédophilie est déclarée en normes une
norme de la vie
et les
religieux sont obligés de donner
bénédiction
mariage homosexuel mais ils peuvent
vivre comme ils veulent on aura toujours
notre opinion surtout cela mais nous ne
voulons pas nous immiscer dans la vie
privée des gens on nous n'avons pas
cette intention mais nous avons quand
même envie de leur dire regardez
la Sainte Bible regardez les autres
livres sacrés des autres religions
toutes est écrit là-dedans la famille
c'est une union entre un homme et une
femme
[Applaudissements]
mais même cela même les textes ça crée
aujourd'hui sont mis en doute
on sait que l'Église américaine pense
pour l'instant c'est un lent de vos de
trouver un Dieu qui serait neutre en
termes de genre
que Dieu leur pardonne et ne savent pas
ce qu'ils font des millions des gens
en Occident comprennent qu'on les emmène
à une catastrophe humanitaire les élites
ont perdu la raison monsieur sont leurs
problèmes comme je l'ai déjà dit nous
nous sommes obligés de protéger nos
enfants contre cette dégradation
[Applaudissements]
va essayer
d'ébranler notre société de s'appuyer
sur des traîtres nationaux qui méprise
leur propre patrie et qui ont envie de
gagner de l'argent en vendant ses
mensonges à ceux qui sont prêts à payer
ceux qui ont pris cette voie de
traîtrise commettent des actes
terroristes contre notre pays contre
l'intégrité territoriale et se rend
punis par la loi mais nous n'allons pas
suivre le régime de qui avait les élites
occidentales nous n'allons pas faire
comme eux et faire la chasse aux
sorcières nous
n'allons pas
poursuivre ceux qui ont perdu le bon
chemin qui ont
oublié leur patrie
mais les citoyens russes leur ont donné
une évolution morale et je suis très
fière de notre peuple multi national
multiethnique
notre peuple et la majorité absolue de
nos citoyens ont une position de
principe concernant l'opération
militaire spéciale il nous soutiennent
il nous soutiennent dans notre réaction
de soutien au don-basse et ce soutien
montre le vrai patriotisme de notre
peuple
notre peuple a toujours eu ce sentiment
ils ont toujours senti que leur destin
est intimement lié au destin de leur
patrie
[Applaudissements]
chers amis je voudrais remercier tout le
monde tout le peuple russe pour le
courage pour la détermination je
voudrais remercier les soldats les
officiers de la flotte de l'armée de
terre des de tous les membres de la
police des forces spéciales des
combattants qui combattent dans le
don-basse
la réserve militaire bars je voudrais
remercier tout le monde je voudrais
seulement m'excuser de ne pas pouvoir
nommer tout le monde
vous savez que pendant la préparation de
mon discours j'avais fait une très
longue liste de
ce régiment ou décès unités héroïques
mais ensuite je décidais de ne pas citer
tout le monde et je ne voulais pas
faire de la peine à ceux que je ne
citerai pas donc j'ai décidé de ne pas
donner la liste complète pour
pas qu'elle soit non exhaustive et je
voudrais vraiment remercier aussi les
familles les femmes également les
médecins personnels par médicaux les
travailleurs des chemins de faire qui
s'occupent de la logistique les
bâtisseurs qui
réhabilitent et reconstruisent des
maisons et des bâtiments également des
ouvriers des ingénieurs des
usines qui travaillent pour l'industrie
de la défense nuit des jours pour
également l'agroalimentaire et tous ceux
qui permettent d'assurer la sécurité
alimentaire
[Applaudissements]
je voudrais remercier également les
enseignants et les procès professeurs
qui s'occupent des jeunes générations
russes surtout ceux qui fonctionnent et
qui travaillent dans des conditions très
difficiles du front également les
collaborateurs de la sphère culturelle
qui viennent au front qui aident
également des volontaires
le journaliste c'est à dire des
correspondants militaires qui viennent
dans
ces territoires pour dire la vérité au
monde entier et également au pas être et
religieux qui viennent également pour se
tenir le moral des troupes je voudrais
remercier également les entrepreneurs
tous ceux qui
remplissent leur devoir leur devoir
civique tout simplement et leur devoir
humain je voudrais remercier tous
spécialement les personnes qui habitent
dans les régions de deniezk et Logan
vous avez
défini votre destin en faisant votre
choix lors des référendums malgré la
terreur des néonazis malgré les combats
qui se passaient juste à côté mais il
n'y avait rien de plus fort que votre
détermination
d'être avec la Russie votre patrie
[Applaudissements]
nous avons déjà commencé
nous allons continuer
je voudrais
souligner je vois la réaction de cette
salle qui soutiennent mes paroles que je
viens de dire pour remercier les
habitants des régions de Daniel que
Louane
encore une fois je les remercie
je disais nous avons commencé le
programme de reconstruction pour ces
territoires il s'agit de reconstruire
les emplois les entreprises les ports de
la mer d'azove de construire de
nouvelles routes comme nous l'avons déjà
fait en Crimée
maintenant une liaison
diable par autoroute avec la Russie le
territoire de la Russie nous allons
octroyer des aides de direct aux
différentes villes de ces quatre
territoires et les gens ont
déjà apporté
tous ensemble nous sommes plus forts et
nous allons tout faire pour que la paix
revienne sur cette terre qui est à nous
donc cette terre sera en paix et
sécurité
[Applaudissements]
pour cela
pour nos ancêtres pour l'avenir des
enfants et des petits-enfants pour
rétablir la justice
historique c'est pour cela que
combattent nos combattants nos héros
chers amis je voudrais vous demander
maintenant une minute deux silence pour
tous ceux qui ont perdu la vie en
combattant mais aussi les villes qui ont
perdu la vie suite aux actions des
néo-nazies et des bataillons punitifs
nous comprenons tous et je comprends que
c'est très dur pour les femmes pour les
filles et les fils de ses combattants
pour les mères
de tous ces héros de krasnodon comme des
troupes qui ont combattu lors de la
grande guerre patriotique tous ceux qui
ont combattu dans le don-basse sont
aussi des héros et toute la Russie les
soutiens
et s'en souvient notre devoir à tous et
des familles et des enfants à obtenir
des métiers et des emplois
tous ces gens qui habitent dans la zone
de l'opération militaire spéciale
doivent être au centre de notre
attention et quand ils font des demandes
il faut répondre immédiatement
[Applaudissements]
je propose de
mettre en place en nouveau fond d'aide
aux familles des personnes qui ont perdu
leur vie pendant l'opération militaire
spéciale
[Applaudissements]
et de sociale financière
réhabilitation
et également
d'aider à trouver un emploi d'améliorer
sa qualification de
faire un autre métier d'acquérir de
nouvelles connaissances et c'est surtout
au l'aide aussi aux familles et aux
personnes blessées qui auront besoin
d'aide à domicile et je demande le
comité qui s'occupe de la politique
sociale également les dirigeants des
régions je vous demande très rapidement
de résoudre tous les problèmes
organisationnels pour ce fond
de Vladimir Poutine on continuera à
l'écouter dans un instant reste avec ses
images depuis
Moscou bonjour Nicolas barrock bonjour
journaliste au service international
spécialiste des questions de défense
vous avez écouté Vladimir Poutine depuis
maintenant une petite demi-heure
toujours ce duel qu'il veut imposer qui
l'impose l'Occident contre la Russie
c'est ça c'est
Poutine là aujourd'hui
et cette d'expliquer dans sa rhétorique
que l'occurence serait responsable de
l'escalade du conflit et de poser cette
Tiger comme un enjeu existentiel pour la
sécurité de la de la Russie mais d'abord
tout ça n'est que de la propagande c'est
de l'habillage mais c'est important pour
son opinion publique en Russie euh de
consolider d'avoir un soutien euh à son
opération militaire parce que son
pouvoir précis il repose sur la capacité
du système russe à soutenir cette
recette donc il doit expliquer et faire
croire à la société russe qu'il y a un
danger et que l'Ukraine et l'Occident
fera poser un danger sur la sécurité de
la Russie l'Ouest cherche un conflit
mondial c'est ce qu'il dit ils veulent
faire d'un conflit local un conflit
global voilà ce qu'il dit sous-entendu
nous nous
occupons que l'Ukraine et eux veulent
détruire à la Russie le le dit souvent
il l'a dit il va nous détruire et
toujours cette menace sans préciser
laquelle nous réagirons bien sûr mais
dès le départ il faut bien avoir en tête
que ce conflit est un conflit
idéologique
n'a jamais eu de menaces évidemment de
de la part de l'Ukraine contre la Russie
et le ranger territorial de ce conflit
est assez limité en fait si Poutine
entre en guerre et envahit l'Ukraine
c'est parce qu'il veut bien défier
l'Occident remettre en cause
l'hégémonie américaine et l'influence de
l'Occident dans le monde pour
reconstruire un ordre nouveau donc dès
le départ le conflit et bien à une
dimension idéologique globale la Russie
vous voulez la paix en Ukraine mais
l'Occident avait d'autres idées voilà ce
qu'il dit nous sommes pacifiques il
retourne vraiment les choses
il parle on le sait discours à la nation
là il parle à son à son peuple ou est-ce
qu'il essaie de faire un passé un
message au niveau international la
preuve ici en France on suit cette
intervention aujourd'hui déjà c'est
George Orwell c'est 84 c'est la peste à
la guerre donc l'inversion des valeurs
c'est une rhétorique assez classique des
dictatures alors il y a passage à son
opinion évidemment il y a autour de mise
en garde cachés envers l'Occident avec
cette idée que il serait prêt à
escalader à aller plus loin à se
défendre ce qui tente de faire croire et
d'expliquer c'est que la Russie serait
davantage prête au risque c'est toujours
été un peu le pari de Poutine depuis le
début de la guerre de croire que
l'Occident aurait peur de soutenir le
cadre a peur de s'engager et publier
c'est pas été le cas pour l'instant
c'est ce que Joe Biden a répété hier en
étant à Kiev mais maintenant Poutine est
dans une dans un engrenage et il ne peut
que surenchérir en fait on revient dans
un instant et on continue de débriefer
ce que dit Vladimir Poutine on l'écoute
le président russe qui évoqué à
l'instant les forces militaires et puis
les perspectives
suite du conflit en Ukraine on écoute
lors des combats donc nos officiers et
tous les militaires qui ont eu cette
expérience de combat vont aller
enseigner dans les différentes
institutions de formation et ces
personnes également vont être présentes
dans les différentes
autorités de tous les niveaux des
autorités civiles pour que toutes ces
personnes sentent que la patrie
reconnaissante à ces personnes pour ce
qu'ils ont fait pour la patrie
donc nous allons mettre en oeuvre des
technologies les dernières technologies
pour améliorer la qualité
de nos équipements nous avons déjà des
développements des
différents systèmes techniques dans les
différents domaines et les
caractéristiques de ces systèmes sont
souvent supérieurs
au système similaire occidentaux
maintenant nous devons mettre leurs
production en série et nous sommes en
train de faire tout ceci d'augmenter la
cadence de production de ces systèmes en
utilisant notre base industrielle et
scientifique je le souligne il y a des
commandes publiques qui sont placés dans
les différentes entreprises nous avons
des usines des bureaux
d'études et nous avons des spécialistes
très talentueux souvent des jeunes qui
sont fidèles à nos traditions et ils
sont prêts à tout faire pour la victoire
[Applaudissements]
nous allons
bien sûr améliorer les garanties pour
les salariés cela concerne les salaires
et le paquet social je propose de lancer
en paquet spécial des
à vous de sushi des projets de logement
c'est pour la location des appartements
et des maisons parce que l'État va
subventionner une partie du loyer pour
ces personnel
nous en avons déjà parlé avec le
gouvernement je vous donne l'instruction
de parler de développer les détails de
ce programme de logement la construction
de ce logement social surtout dans les
villes qui sont importantes pour notre
industrie de la défense et des centres
de recherche scientifiques chers
collègues je l'ai déjà dit l'Occident a
lancé contre nous non seulement
des fonds militaires en formationnels
mais aussi économique mais ils n'ont
rien obtenu nulle part ils ne vont rien
obtenir
[Applaudissements]
plus que cela ceux qui ont initié les
sanctions ce sont punis eux-mêmes
augmentations de prix augmentation du
chômage crise énergétique
tout cela subissent les citoyens
occidentaux et qu'est-ce qu'ils
entendent ils entendent que c'est la
faute de la Russie
c'est une agression par sanction contre
la Russie on a essayé de rompre les
liens économiques avec la Russie nous
ils ont essayé de déconnecter notre
système
financier nous privés de l'accès au
marché des exportations et
ils ont aussi volé nos réserves en
devises et ils ont essayé de faire
effondrer le rouble pour provoquer
l'inflation je vous répète les sanctions
anti russes c'est juste un moyen quel
est l'objectif ils le disent eux-mêmes
les dirigeants occidentaux je cite c'est
de faire souffrir nos citoyens c'est ce
qu'ils disent
qui sont les humanistes voyez-vous ils
essaient de faire souffrir le peuple
pour déstabiliser notre société de
l'intérieur c'est ce qu'il voulait mais
ils ont échoué le système de gestion en
Russie et l'économie russe a été plus
forte ils ont
le Parlement la banque centrale les
systèmes financier le gouvernement et
bien sûr les entrepreneurs tout cela
nous a permis à garder notre économie à
flot à
soutenir les emplois soutenir le système
financier
cela nous a permis de continuer à
développer notre pays en mars dernier
nous avons lancé en paquet de soutien au
business et à l'économie un trillion de
roubles a été consacré à ce projet et je
voudrais souligner
[Musique]
ce n'est pas la politique d'émission de
billets nous
utilisons une base de l'économie de
marché très solide
le PIB
2022 ABC
Michael
bien sûr c'était dans les délais nous
avons toujours nos plans
et
prévoyait on voulait que notre économie
baisse de 25% ensuite on a dit de
virgules 9,5 le PIB
2022 a baissé de
2,1%. ça c'est les dernières données que
nous avons
et je voudrais vous rappeler en février
mars on disait que notre économie a
laissé fonder
les entrepreneurs russes ont su
reconstruire leur schéma logistique et
de s'adapter
ez également souligner la part du
horrible dans nos échanges extérieurs
maintenant cela représente un tiers
c'est deux fois plus qu'il y a un an et
si on prend en compte les devises des
pays amicaux c'est plus de la moitié de
toutes les devises nous allons continuer
à développer un système financier qui
est indépendant du dollar et des devises
occidentales
c'est devise vont perdre leur caractère
universel à cause de la politique des
dirigeants occidentaux ils le font
eux-mêmes
voilà
Vladimir Poutine on continue d'écouter
son discours et puis on l'analyse en
même temps Nicolas Barotte c'est
intéressant ce qu'il dit les sanctions
occidentales avaient pour objectif de
faire souffrir le peuple russe c'est ce
que disent les dirigeants occidentaux
alors que bien souvent c'est tout
l'inverse que disent les dirigeants
occidentaux on veut attaquer le pouvoir
russe mais certainement pas le peuple
russe ah oui alors de fait les sanctions
et que l'économique ont un impact des
populations et malheureusement c'est
vrai tout le discours de Poutine c'est
effectivement de se victimiser pour
justifier son agression son invasion de
de l'Ukraine donc ça ça passe par les
hommages aux morts en soldats en
expliquant que c'est les Ukrainiens
nazis et essayer de leur soutien qui
sont responsables de ces semaines on a
vu mine de silence une solennité de
Poutine il y a l'aspect économique en
disant voilà la société russe souffre
c'est à cause de l'Occident tout ça ça a
conduit en fait un paradoxal c'est que
aujourd'hui effectivement Poutine est
davantage soutenu par son opinion qui ne
l'était au début du conflit parce que au
fur et à mesure la propagande des médias
russe et du pouvoir russe et la dureté
la situation et sous une part un peu de
culture qui est assez enracinée dans la
société russe fait que les gens ont
réussi sont sont convaincus pour une
partie effectivement la Russie est aussi
agressée par par l'Occident évidemment
tout ça c'est une construction c'est une
manipulation d'une façon pour Poutine de
justifier son agression mais parce que
c'est important aussi pour lui de de ne
pas avoir une société qui se fragilise
et dans son discours il a aussi
mentionné un fond d'aide pour pour les
pour les familles
pour les familles voilà il a bien
conscience que il doit aussi avoir une
dimension sociale pour que les gens qui
sont mobilisés qui partent en front
ne traînent pas trop des pieds on sent
que c'est difficile on a vu au moment de
la première mobilisation toutes ces
fuites
qui qui t'aident le pays c'est un vrai
c'est un vrai danger un vrai souci pour
la Russie parce que si elle veut pouvoir
mener ses offensives elle a besoin
d'avoir de la masse comme on dit c'est
les militaires sur le terrain c'est
intéressant il semble y avoir une sorte
d'orientation vers une économie de
guerre il dit par exemple qu'il va
favoriser la construction de logements
dans les lieux où il y aurait des usines
de fabrication
d'armes il y a une vraie dynamique dans
le sens en Russie depuis un an
l'économie rue s'est passée en économie
de guerre en fait alors c'est assez
difficile d'avoir des éléments factuels
parce que les Occidentaux ont peu
d'accès à une formation mais on voit
bien que les embauches dans les dans ces
usines ont augmenté on voit bien qu'il y
a un soutien pour envoyer des gens
travailler et produire alors il y a une
difficulté pour la Russie parce qu'elle
manque de composants de matières qui
sont utiles pour fabriquer des missiles
de haute précision mais malgré tout pour
fabriquer de la revente basique là la
Russie a les capacités et donc c'est ce
mécanisme là que Poutine a mis en place
pour durer parce que ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est que la guerre de la
Russie c'est une guerre qui sera longue
dès le départ il avait l'intention de de
mener une offensive très longue contre
l'Occident et là il s'est préparé
on continue d'écouter Vladimir Poutine
et puis on se retrouve ensuite Nicolas
Barotte journaliste au service
international on écoute le chef du
Kremlin
de l'économie
la base ni pastaf que sérieusement
l'accent sur les exportations non pas à
des drocarbures mais des biens
ajoutées
nous prévoyons déjà cette année une
augmentation de la demande intérieure et
je pense que nos sociétés vont utiliser
cette occasion pour augmenter la
production des produits
les plus demandés pour prendre les
niches qui ont été libérées par les
compagnies occidentales qui ont quitté
le marché russe nous voyons aujourd'hui
quelles sont les problèmes structurels
que nous devons résoudre en termes de
logistique technologies finances et au
capital humain nous n'avons parlé
beaucoup de la nécessité de changer la
structure de notre économie depuis
plusieurs années et aujourd'hui c'est
devenu vital de faire ses évolutions
cela change la situation est dans ce
cas-là cela l'améliore nous savons ce
que nous devons faire pour permettre à
la Russie d'avancer pour que ce
développement soit souverain indépendant
et qu'il soit indépendant donc malgré
les pressions qui puisse venir de
l'extérieur je voudrais souligner
que ce que nous faisons c'est ne pas
nous adapter aux conditions actuelles
mais nous poursuisons poursuivons un
objectif structurel d'attendre de
nouveaux objectifs aujourd'hui tout
change très vite
c'est un temps de défis mais c'est aussi
un teint d'opportunité en tant
d'opportunités
et donc au tout dépend de nous l'avenir
de notre pays
dépend de nos actions et nous devons
supprimer les contradictions entre les
différents ministères entre les
différentes
étapes de la machine étatique pour
permettre aux
entreprises de se développer quand il y
a de nouvelles entreprises qui s'ouvrent
c'est déjà une victoire l'ouverture de
nouvelles voies de chemin de fer c'est
la victoire ouverture de nouvelles
écoles l'ouverture
les nouvelles
découvert scientifiques c'est aussi
notre victoire tout cela se lève la
victoire
sur quoi devons-nous
nous concentrer c'est-à-dire le
partenariat entre le niveau central et
le niveau régional
il faut
augmenter les liaisons logistiques et
les couloirs notamment la route Moscou
Kazan devrait être prolongée jusqu'à
hier que dire une bourse qui est humide
ensuite jusqu'à erkoud que la Divo stock
il devrait également avoir des accès aux
Kazakhstan et à la Mongolie tout cela ça
permettra de d'être mieux connecté avec
les marchés de l'Asie du Sud-Est nous
allons également développer les ports de
la mer Noire et la mère d'Azov
et
nous allons
également prêté une attention
particulière au couloir international
Nord-Sud
nous allons pouvoir ouvrir des voies
maritimes qui nous ouvrira de nouvelles
possibilités de coopération avec l'angle
de Pakistan et d'autres pays nous allons
continuer à développer ses couloirs et
un moderniser également nos chemins de
fer
à
l'estrancible et bam ce sont des chemins
de fer mais ce n'est pas seulement
l'augmentation du fret c'est aussi
les objectifs de développement de la
Sibérie et de l'Extrême Orient nous
allons développer nos infrastructures y
compris de télécommunications les autos
route en 2024
et il y aura 85 % d'autoroute dans les
grandes villes et la moitié des routes
du niveau
régional et municipal en termes
municipale vont être au niveau
nécessaire qui correspond à nos normes
nous allons continuer le programme de
gazification
gratuite surtout équipé les maternelles
les écoles les centres médicaux les
hôpitaux
maintenant ce sera un programme
permanent et les gens pourraient
s'adresser dans ce programme pour
pouvoir être connecté au réseau gazier
donc si on a envie de connecter sa
maison et depuis cette année nous allons
lancer un nouveau programme de
réhabilitation des systèmes
urbains 4,3 millions de roubles seront
consacrés à cela dans les trois ans à
venir nous connaissons tous les
problèmes qu'on connaît ce secteur des
services urbains il est important que ce
programme démarre très vite donc je
confie au gouvernement d'assurer en
financement stable ensuite il faut
augmenter les capacités technologiques
de l'économie russe de l'industrie russe
et nous avons déjà lancé un programme
d'hypothèque industrielle c'est-à-dire
on pourra obtenir un crédit au taux
préférentiel pour l'achat des
des infrastructures industrielles mais
pour leur modernisation aussi
ce crédit pourrait aller jusqu'au 500
millions de roubles c'est déjà en
premier pas 3 à 5 % pour une échéance de
échéance de 7 ans c'est un bon programme
je pense que les personnes intéressées
devraient utiliser
depuis cette année nous avons également
lancé un régime de cluster
industriel
où il y a des conditions fiscales
préférentielles et notamment les
produits qui sont lancés sur le marché
profitent également des subventions
toutes ces mesures devraient à l'horizon
2035 30 pardon
de permettre
à réaliser nos objectifs des
investisseurs de 10 d'investissement de
10 trillions de roubles et cela peut
déjà atteindre deux trillions cette
année ce ne sont pas des pronostics
c'est un plan ce sont des orientations
que nous avons définies
on continue de l'écouter le président
russe intéressant il parle d'ouverture
économique vers l'Est on fait une petite
pause dans son discours parce que c'est
vrai que là il parle on peuple russe de
mesure très précises donc on essaie
d'analyser ce qu'il dit sur le plan
international ouverture économique vers
l'Est il abandonné l'Ouest c'est terminé
c'est fermé c'est que maintenant on est
dans la nouvelle guerre froide et il y a
plus de possibilités de 1 de
reconstruire quoi que ce soit avec
l'Ouest pour l'instant ce qui est
intéressant c'est que ce discours
effectivement il s'adresse au peuple
russe des messages à l'Occident mais il
y a aussi des messages en fait au reste
du monde oui pour un aligner finalement
et non aligné et pour essayer pour la
réussite de trouver des débouchés pour
son économie de trouver des alliés
éventuellement pour ceux qui voudra
remettre en cause la puissance et
l'hégémonie occidentales donc ce
discours il est aussi à destination de
des non-aligny absolument nous sommes
imbattables sur le terrain il le savent
voilà ce que disait tout à l'heure
Vladimir Poutine alors il nous attaque
sur les valeurs l'influence
l'information
ça aussi c'est intéressant il le veut
dire à son peuple que sur le terrain ça
ne marche pas ne pas se laisser
déstabiliser par les ingérences
étrangères qui peuvent apparaître sur
son territoire absolument il y a donc
des difficultés pour l'armée russe
depuis un an sur le terrain la patte en
mesure de remporter cette guerre qu'elle
a déclenché et donc Poutine a trouvé des
explications c'est des difficultés et
donc l'explication la plus facile c'est
de dire que c'est le l'Occident qui est
en guerre par procuration contre contre
la Russie
nous sommes fascifiques voilà ce que
disait tout à l'heure Vladimir Poutine
sachez que Jordan Meloni est arrivé à
Kiev là
la première ministre italienne la
présidente du Conseil italien elle qui
n'avait pas été du voyage à Paris
lorsque zenki étaient venus
vers l'Occident à Londres et à Paris
est-ce que ce qu'il s'est passé hier
avec la visite de Joe Biden influence le
discours en
Ukraine influence le discours
aujourd'hui de Vladimir Poutine sans
doute que ça pousse ou que ça permet à
Poutine de durcir son son discours c'est
un peu compliqué d'ailleurs parce que
quand les Occidentaux manifestent un
soutien ferme clair à l'Ukraine que ce
soit en expliquant comme on l'a fait
l'Élysée que il faut une défaite de la
Russie comme quand Joe Biden va à Kiev
tout ça est réutilisé et instrumentalisé
ensuite par la Russie pour mettre en
scène justifier cette pseudo agression
là on est typiquement de la guerre
internationale avec des messages qui
sont envoyés
effectivement pour tenter d'influencer
les opinions publiques de les faire
douter de les fragiliser on lui
renforcer comme c'est le cas en fait ce
qui est amusant c'est de voir c'est que
le discours du président là n'est plus
accessible sur certains sites russes ah
bon alors on se passe c'est une
cyberattaque c'est une panne on peut se
poser la question légitimement donc là
ce que disent Vladimir Poutine elle
n'est pas accessible en Russie sur
certains après pour voir sur quel
deuxième certains médias sur certains
médias la page de retransmis le discours
et en panne donc accessible donc il y a
sans doute on peut supposer là aussi une
façon pour les Ukrainiens leur soutien
on ne sait pas d'aller attaquer Poutine
sur le terrain informationnel on écoute
et on continue d'écouter ce discours à
la nation de Vladimir Poutine
donc je demande aux député de lancer un
programme pour permettre
de profiter des capacités de financement
interne c'est à dire qu'on doit
permettre aux gens aussi de recevoir une
rémunération sur leur argent
il s'agit aussi de l'assurance
pour les
d'argent qui est placé dans la banque
et également pour les fonds de pension
pour une retraite par capitalisation de
donner une garantie de l'argent qui est
placé sur ses fonds également il faut
protéger l'argent qui est l'argent des
citoyens qui est placé dans d'autres
fonds et instruments
il faut prendre des mesures pour
attirer les capitaux dans les industries
de haute technologie il faut
des régimes préférentiels pour
la taxation pour développer également
l'entreprise l'entrepreneuriat
le secteur privé a déjà prouvé qui sait
s'adapter pour des conditions qui
changent très vite dans des conditions
très difficiles cela a permis de
soutenir la croissance économique du
pays donc chaque initiative dans ce sens
doit être soutenu
[Applaudissements]
qu'il faut revoir
certaines lois le code pénal en ce qui
concerne des crimes économiques bien sûr
l'État doit pouvoir contrôler ce qui se
passe dans ce domaine et on ne peut pas
laisser tout faire mais
il faut aller vers une décliminalisation
le gouvernement avec le Parlement la
police et les associations des
entrepreneurs devraient faire ce travail
donc avec le Parlement on doit proposer
de nouvelles mesures
pour l'économie
et surtout de faire revenir les
entrepreneurs des offshore il faut
qu'ils fonctionnent à l'intérieur de la
Russie
sur le territoire national et à cet
égard je voudrais faire un commentaire
philosophique en quelque sorte
de nos problèmes des déséquilibres
à une époque soviétique
nous nous souvenons du chaos des années
90 et après
c'est dans ces conditions qui a été créé
une nouvelle économie de marché et
l'Institut de
la propriété privée et nous ne sommes
appuyés sur les pays occidentaux il y a
eu beaucoup de conseillers
les Tortes conseillers mais
ils savaient pas très bien en quel
modèle nous proposait je me souviens que
les Européens ont été en discussion avec
les Américains pour savoir quel était le
meilleur modèle et qu'est-ce qu'on a
obtenu notre économie nationale
finalement a été orienté vers l'économie
occidentale mais surtout en tant que
source
des ressources naturelles
qui est business on comprend les raisons
les nouvelles entreprises
russes comme partout avait comme premier
objectif d'obtenir un bénéfice rapide
maximale et qu'est-ce qui était le plus
simple c'était de vendre des ressources
naturelles de gaz le pétrole les métaux
le bois mais
il y avait pas beaucoup de gens qui
pensaient aux investissements à long
terme pour développer des
secteurs économiques et plus complexe
donc il y a eu peu d'investissements
nous avons eu besoin de plusieurs années
pour casser ce système nous avons eu des
investissements publics et privés
massifs pour changer cette tendance
et nous avons réussi mais il faut se
souvenir qu'elle était les circonstances
du développement de nos entreprises les
technologies
occidentales les marchés
occidentaux les moyens de financer donc
tout ça c'était
occidental et les capitaux ont commencé
à enfuir vers l'Occident donc à la place
d'investir dans les nouvelles
technologies ici chez nous en Russie de
les emplois ces moyens étaient utilisés
pour s'acheter des maisons des villas
des yachts
donc ça c'était la première étape
ensuite peut-être que il y avait aussi
des investissements mais en tout cas
dans un premier temps c'était surtout la
consommation de ces capitaux et
évidemment
là on met son capital on met aussi ses
enfants ont les met dans les
établissements d'éducation supérieure
on voit son avenir là-bas on était dans
des conditions dans marché libre mais
maintenant
on voit les derniers événements ont
montré que l'Occident n'est pas ce
sanctuer et ceux qui pensaient que la
Russie
c'est seulement la source de ce criant
capital et ensuite il voulait partir
vivre à l'Occident tous ces gens ont
compris leur erreur aujourd'hui parce
qu'ils ont été volés on leur a pris le
ressources et il y avait une blague
je me suis adressée aux représentants
des milieux d'affaires russes je leur ai
dit mais ça va vous être très difficile
vous allez avaler beaucoup de poussière
en essayant de d'aller dans les
différentes instances pour obtenir
justice et j'avais raison et je voudrais
ajouter quelque chose de très simple
parmi les simples citoyens de notre pays
personne n'a eu pitié de ceux qui ont
perdu leur capitaux qui étaient investis
dans les banques
occidentales
il parle de la fuite des capitaux il dit
que personne ne s'inquiète de ceux qui
ont perdu des maisons à cause de
l'Occident depuis le début de cette
guerre c'est un tacle aux oligarques là
il se met une partie des puissances
financières du pays ado en disant ça
c'est une menace surtout et ce 17 jours
sur les traîtres à la nation c'est une
figure assez classique il a déjà utilisé
lors d'un précédent discours
c'est une menace à ceux qui seraient
tenté
de fuir de se désolidariser
ça leur signifie qu'ils sont connus
identifiés et que le pouvoir de Poutine
ne lui laissera pas
fuir comme il le communion qui parle au
peuple s'il y a un côté populiste d'une
certaine manière regardez c'est riche
qui vous prennent tout moi je suis avec
vous et je vais les faire revenir pour
qu'il paye les impôts et qui vous
puissiez vivre dans le meilleur
conditions bien sûr c'est c'est une
rhétorique populiste assez classique
d'aller viser
une sorte de corrompu que Poutine
serait l'ennemi après à s'en prendre à
eux
donc plus compliqué et le le système
Poutine est imbriqué avec un pouvoir
financier donc
il y a une il y a un discours il y a
volonté effectivement de flatter
l'opinion en s'en prenant assez oligares
cette figure un peu de celui qui s'est
enrichi d'aventure des années 90 période
de libéralisation
effrénées qui a été extrêmement dur pour
la Russie après la la chute de l'Union
soviétique qui a laissé pendant un
traumatisme dans la société russe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le pignon russe et dans celle-là ou une
nouvelle fois ce conflit est aussi un
conflit idéologique il y a le combat sur
le terrain extrêmement dur en Ukraine
mais au fond et c'est là où c'est un
terrible pour pour le monde c'est qu'il
y a une guerre froide une opposition
entre entre deux visions du monde
l'Occident et c'est la valeur
démocratie liberté avec les limites
qu'on connaît et de l'autre côté la 1 la
Russie qui défend notre modèle de
pouvoir fort et que Poutine va incarner
merci beaucoup Nicolas Barotte on
continue d'écouter Vladimir Poutine le
président russe on écoute son discours
jusqu'à la fin ça fait aller 1h05 1h10
qu'il a pris la parole et on continue de
l'écouter la fin du discours de Vladimir
Poutine
inutile de
mendier
le retour de ces capitaux qui ont été
confisqués vous êtes des personnes
fortes je voudrais m'adresser aux
représentants des milieux des affaires
russes vous êtes très fort vous avez eu
une vie difficile comme une école vous
pouvez lancer de nouveau projet
investissez dans des projets en Russie
et des à créer des emplois et des
universités financées la science et le
sport mais ici en Russie et vous allez
augmenter votre capital et vous allez
aussi
acheter une reconnaissance de la part du
peuple russe et le l'État et le
gouvernement vous soutiendra
[Applaudissements]
donc en quelque sorte c'est le message à
nos entrepreneurs pour aller dans le bon
sens
c'est une
civilisation
qui est la nôtre qui est différente des
autres
je ne demande pas quelque chose
d'exceptionnel je ne parle pas de ça
mais nous avons notre propre
identité et nous allons transmettre cela
aux nouvelles générations et nous allons
bien sûr un travail avec les autres et à
s'inspirer des autres exemples mais nous
allons surtout nous appuyer sur notre
tradition au lycée je voudrais surtout
parler de notre peuple russe et de son
caractère il a toujours été un peuple
généreux un peuple compatissant Ant
écologique de Jette Sony nous savons
être de bons amis de d'être fidèles un
autre parole on peut compter sur nous
dans chaque situation difficile on porte
l'aide sans réfléchir à tous ceux qui en
ont besoin en sont à la pandémie nous
avons aidé les pays européens notamment
en Italie et d'autres lors des semaines
les plus difficiles de la pandémie
je voudrais rappeler également
comment nous aidons les populations qui
ont été frappées par les tremblements de
terre en Surie et en Syrie et en Turquie
la souveraineté de notre pays ça c'est
important les droits et les libertés de
notre peuple ce sont des valeurs
qui nous sommes chers qui sont toujours
là
je voudrais souligner
quand il s'agit des élections de cette
année les élections locales et puis
d'autres élections régionales tout cela
c'est élections vont être menées selon
la loi
les élections c'est toujours liées à la
solution des différentes problèmes
sociaux et économique mais pour nous le
problème est l'enjeu principal c'est la
sécurité et la prospérité la
souveraineté de notre pays je voudrais
vous remercier pour votre position au
ferme et responsable je voudrais
vous rappeler les paroles de monsieur
tolépine qui ont été prononcées il y a
plus de 100 ans
ce Lépine a dit que quand il s'agit de
la protection de la Russie nous devons
tous
conjuguer nos efforts et utiliser nos
droits et nos engagements pour réaliser
le droit le plus suprême le droit de la
Russie d'être forte
[Applaudissements]
parmi les volontaires qui sont sur le
terrain aujourd'hui
il y a des
parlementaires
il y a de représentants des
municipalités
tous les partis du Parlement les
différentes associations
participent à la collecte humanitaire
pour aider le front je voudrais
remercier encore une fois tout le monde
pour votre engagement patriotique
[Applaudissements]
de la société civile
c'est également
la tâche qu'effectue le niveau local
le niveau régional des autorités ces
autorités jouent un rôle extrêmement
important et je demande à
l'administration présidentielle et au
gouvernement de créer des instruments
pour soutenir les meilleures équipes de
gouvernance des municipalités
c'est la possibilité d'être responsable
responsable de soi-même de sa famille et
de son pays
et tout cela ça se forme au sang des
familles et pour
former la jeunesse c'est l'éducation et
la culture
qui sont très importantes et bien en
fond de dotation présidentielle il y a
d'autres
fonds et d'autres systèmes de soutien
pour soutenir les différentes
initiatives dans ce domaine
doit servir le la bonté la beauté
également la paix
permettre aux gens de réfléchir aux
problèmes difficiles de ne pas détruire
mais au contraire de soutenir ou de
développement de meilleures qualités
humaines
[Applaudissements]
de la culture ce sera également la
priorité lors du de la reconstruction
pacifique du don-basse il faudra
reconstituer les musées les
réserves de ces musées
il faudra que les personnes puissent
connaître leur histoire leur passé leur
présent pour regarder vers l'avenir
il faudrait qu'il soit conscient de
l'histoire
séculaire de la Russie nous devons
améliorer très sérieusement elle est
cursus scolaire
de l'histoire-géographie des sciences
humaines d'une manière générale pour que
les jeux ne puissent connaître et savoir
plus sur l'histoire et sur le grand
passé de la Russie nous avons des
professeurs retraites talentueux qui
sont vraies qui sont prêts à travailler
dans tous les secteurs et nous avons
également les entreprises qui sont prêts
à y travailler
nous avons des concours que nous
organisons comme les leaders de
renaissance nous avons déjà des gagnants
de ces projets et ces gagnants souvent
ce sont engagés en tant que volontaire
pour aller sur le front mais pour
également rétablir
la vie économique sur les territoires
libérés
la l'école du front l'école des combats
c'est irremplaçable les gens qui y vont
ils sont prêts à donner leur vie pour
leur patrie
je voudrais souligner les gens qui sont
nés dans le don de base dans la nouveau
Russia
c'est ces gens qui doivent
être ceux sur qui nous appuyons quand
nous travaillons dans ces régions la
Russie compte sur vous
[Applaudissements]
objectifs qui sont devant notre pays
nous devons repenser notre système de
formation La formation notamment de nos
chercheurs nous avons récemment parlé
des priorités nous devons bien connaître
ses priorités et de nous fixer les
objectifs notamment dans le domaine
scientifique et il faut atteindre des
résultats significatifs surtout dans les
domaines importants dans le domaine
aussi du transport énergies services
urbains médecine agriculture industrie
et souvent il s'agit d'une base des
sciences dures des recherches dans ces
domaines et dans ce domaine aussi bien
que dans la culture nous devons donner
aux scientifiques et aux chercheurs plus
de liberté pour être créatif
nous ne pouvons pas
à chaque fois demander des résultats
immédiatement les sciences dures
sciences fondamentales ils ont leur
propre règles et nous devons stimuler
les jeunes pour qu'ils viennent plus
massivement dans ce domaine scientifique
nous devons prouver au monde entier que
nous avons de quoi être fiers en
décembre dernier j'ai rencontré les
jeunes chercheurs et une des questions
qui m'ont posé concerné le logement
c'est peut-être une question banale mais
c'est la réalité nous avons déjà lancé
un programme d'aide un certificat de
logement nous avons croyant milliards de
roubles l'année dernière je
leur donne au gouvernement de d'élargir
ce programme depuis un an
le système d'enseignement secondaire
professionnel a eu également
plus de déclare améliorer sa réputation
il faut
améliorer
le système de former des clusters de
formation les entreprises
dans l'élaboration des cursus pour que
ça soit des
spécialiste qui sont demandés sur le
marché de travail ce sont pas de gâteau
très concret nous devons en cinq ans
préparer un million de nouveaux
spécialistes pour
une industrie la pharmaceutique
l'agriculture les voies publiques les
transports
le secteur
nucléaire la
également pour soutenir la souveraineté
et
la compétitivité de la Russie encore
je voudrais parler de notre école
supérieure elle a également
supérieur doit tenir compte deux
nouvelles exigences et de nouveau
spécialistes demandées dans les
différents secteurs économiques
nous devons nous appuyer sur tout ce que
ce qui existait déjà dans le système
soviétique et de l'expérience de ces
dernières années nous devons
retourner à
la préparation des spécialistes
selon un socle de base
[Applaudissements]
à 6 ans de formation et cela peut être
une spécialité un établissement
mais on peut proposer plusieurs
programmes concernant en fonction de la
demande du marché de travail si une
telle profession demande des
spécialistes encore plus pointues de
tels étudiants et diplômés pourraient
continuer leurs enseignes pour préparer
un diplôme de maîtrise ou autre appareil
une thèse il faudrait également avoir
ces établissements qui permettent de
former du futur scientifiques et nous
devons changer pour passer ce nouveau
système le gouvernement et les
parlementaires
vont devoir introduire beaucoup de
dans la loi pour tout prévoir jusqu'au
moindre détail à la jeunesse nos
citoyens doit avoir de nouvelles
possibilités pour une formation de
qualité pour pouvoir trouver du travail
de qualité encore une fois des
opportunités et pas des problèmes
[Applaudissements]
vont pouvoir continuer à suivre les
programmes actuels
qui existent déjà
de Bachelor notamment de Master et
autres nœuds ont pas être révisés
[Musique]
en ce qui concerne les professeurs et
les enseignants ce sont des gens qui
participent à la construction de
l'avenir de notre pays et les parents
devraient plus attirer l'attention de
leurs enfants sur le rôle de leur
professeur nous devons toujours
si vous souvenirs
également parler du soutien aux familles
et aux enfants
a été multiplié
qui augmente le plus
national je voudrais remercier les
parlementaires et le gouvernement le
gouvernement pour cette compréhension de
nos priorités nationales à partir du 1er
février le capital maternité a été
indexée de nouveau et cette indexation
est égale à 11,9% c'est équivaut au taux
d'inflation
les citoyens aux Russes de nouveaux
territoires ont droit également à ce
capital de mer
dans les régions de denièvre Logan
les familles recevront aussi ce capital
même pour les familles qui ont des
enfants qui sont nés après 2007
ce programme a été instauré en Russie
je voudrais vous rappeler que pour les
citoyens de la Crimée et de Sébastopol
nous avons introduit ce programme
également dans les mêmes conditions
et les parlementaires doivent aussi
s'appelaient sur une augmentation des
salaires le salaire minimum notamment
doit augmenter
les deux augmentations l'an dernier de
presque 20% et nous allons continuer à
augmenter
ce salaire minimum et à chaque fois ces
augmentations vont être supérieures et
que
l'inflation depuis le début de l'année
cette augmentation a constitué ici sur
b3% et à partir de 1er janvier de
l'année prochaine je propose
en complément de ce qui a été déjà prévu
augmenter ce salaire de qui pour cent
cette augmentation constituera 18,5%
donc du salaire minimum
19242 roubles le salaire un minimum
d'eau
le système fiscal pour soutenir les fans
ses familles vont être exonérées
de mutation quand ils achètent au ventes
leur logement nous devons tout faire
pour donner plus de moyens aux familles
parce que c'est les familles qui sont à
la base de solutions des différents
problèmes
donc en ce qui concerne les allocations
pour l'éducation des enfants cela va
doubler de 50000 à 100 000 et également
d'autres allocations
ce sont
en fait des sommes qui sont frappées
ensuite par l'impôt sur les revenus mais
l'État va
compenser
rembourser 13% de cette impôts aux
familles
sous un régime proactif c'est-à-dire que
ça doit être très facile d'obtenir ce
remboursement augmenter la qualité de
vie de famille cela améliorera la
démographie et je sais que dans beaucoup
d'entités de fédération il y a des
programmes pour améliorer les
différentes
infrastructures de culture de sport
amélioré des logements qui sont de
mauvaise qualité nous allons soutenir
tous ces programmes le budget fédéral en
2024 a prévu un programme
social
donc cet argent serait versé aux régions
dès maintenant
grâce au crédit à taux zéro et en avril
de l'année prochaine c'est crédits
seront
automatiquement considérés comme
rembourser
et donc c'est un très bon mécanisme nous
allons le contrôler de très près et la
Commission du conseil de l'État sur les
finances doit avoir ça sous contrôle
ces constructions des infrastructures
doivent être de haute qualité et ses
ressources financières
ils doivent faire la différence en ce
qui concerne la santé également en 2021
il y a eu en grand au programme de
soutien massif je voudrais que les
dirigeants des régions
le critère ce ne sont pas des chiffres
dans vos rapports mais les résultats
très concrets et tangibles en ce qui
concerne l'accessibilité des services de
soins
je confie au gouvernement et également
de faire évoluer les lois qui concernent
l'achat de pièces détachées pour
l'industrie
c'est-à-dire que les
bilan de santé doivent pouvoir se faire
directement dans l'entreprise nous avons
lancé un programme de rénovation des
écoles
3,5
bâtiments d'écoles devraient être
rénovés
surtout dans les milieux ruraux et
encore une fois je souligne que dans les
oblasters
en 2025 ce budget fédéral qui sera
transférer au niveau régional sera
régulier donc pour rénover ses bâtiments
vétuste
[Musique]
objectif pour la période entre 2019 et
construire beaucoup de nouvelles écoles
il y a déjà 850
à partir de 2019 jusqu'en 2024 presque
490 milliards de roubles doivent être
consacrés à ce programme et aux rythme
sera soutenu
cette année nous avons augmenté le
volume des crédits pour les
infrastructures
de transport et logistique en complément
je souligne de ce qui était déjà prévu
je propose d'ajouter encore 50 milliards
d'euros et cela va contribuer à
améliorer les transports publics en
utilisant les technologies très modernes
et je voudrais que une attention
particulière soit apportée aux
îles aux petites villes et au village
dans notre pays
nous avons ce programme qui concerne
notamment les
entreprises nous avons toujours cet
objectif qui est toujours là de diminuer
de manière significative les émissions
toxiques
des programmes de gestion de déchets le
passage économie circulaire la
liquidation des décharges des vieilles
décharges je demande au gouvernement et
aux dirigeants des régions déjà
préparées la liste des différents sites
qui doivent être
liquidés après la fin de ce programme et
nous allons également rétablir
rénover les différents autres
projets nous avons des sites naturels
sur les différentes rivières et fleuves
dont nous devons nous occuper
à peu près plus d'une heure et demie de
discours le président
russement de la situation en Russie
c'était éloigné un peu même si
complètement de du conflit en Ukraine
bonjour Philippe Gély bonjour directeur
adjoint de la rédaction du Figaro en
charge de l'international on essaie
d'expliquer de débriefer ce que dit
Vladimir Poutine et puis évidemment vous
ne raterez pas la fin de du discours du
président russe votre première
impression toujours
cette opposition entre l'Occident et la
Russie là il y a deux blocs c'est ce
qu'il veut faire passer clairement mais
ce qui me frappe c'est que le président
russe bien sûr enfin ce qu'il décrit
c'est une guerre totale
que lui livre l'Occident qu'il subit
selon lui puisqu'il a même affirmé que
c'était les
Occidentaux qu'il y avait déclenché la
guerre et qui lui utilisait la force
pour l'arrêter ce qui est quand même une
lecture un peu particulière des
événements
sur le sens simplement factuel
puisque quand même factuellement des
colonnes blindées russes qui envahit
l'Ukraine le 24 février 2022 mais bon
ce qui me frappe aussi c'est que dans
toute la deuxième partie du discours en
fait on a l'impression que la guerre
permet à Poutine de façonner la Russie
dont qu'il veut la Russie de ses rêves
la Russie parfaite la Russie qui est
cette antioxydant il accuse les
Occidentaux de vouloir créer une anti
Russie mais lui
profite entre guillemets de l'occasion
que de la guerre enfin des circonstances
de la guerre pour créer une Russie qui
soit un antioxydant qui soit un projet
qui est un projet de très long terme ou
on prend les enfants dès l'école où on
leur inculque un patriotisme
très très clairement défini
basé sur la religion orthodoxe sur la
Bible sur les valeurs traditionnelles et
on leur inculque dès l'enfance donc en
fait tout ce que décrivent la lumière
Poutine ce sont des projets de très long
terme que ce qu'il parle d'écologie
qu'il parle d'économie qu'il parle qu'il
propose aux
exilés russes on sait que beaucoup de
jeunes notamment de cerveau de gens qui
sont à la pointe de la dans la
technologie sont partis presque un
million de Russes sont partis pour
échapper à la conscription il leur
propose de revenir
parce que il est en train à l'entendre
de créer une Russie idéale une Russie
presque autosuffisante qui ne s'appuie
que sur ces quelques amis qui n'a
absolument pas besoin de l'Occident ni
de ces marchés ni de ses ressources
financières ni surtout de ses valeurs ce
qui témoigne peut-être encore un peu
plus du fait que cette guerre elle a pas
une vocation à
augmenter le territoire russe elle a pas
un objectif territorial c'est vraiment
autre chose
l'un n'exclut pas l'autre non non c'est
si important que ça au vu de la taille
de la Russie c'est quelques blast dans
l'Est depuis les oblast c'est ce que la
Russie l'armée russe a conquis pour
l'instant
18% du territoire ukrainien ça n'est pas
nécessairement son objectif final il
faut garder à l'esprit que pour Poutine
et c'est encore clair dans son discours
d'aujourd'hui l'Ukraine n'existe pas
l'Ukraine c'est c'est un ils ont il a
parlé à un moment de polygone en fait
c'est un c'est un champ de manœuvre que
qu'on utilisait des Occidentaux à la
tête duquel ils ont mis un régime
néo-nazi il a parlé d'ailleurs de du
fait qu'il ne descendèrent contre le
peuple ukrainien selon lui mais
seulement contre un régime prétendument
des eaux nazis à la solde des
Occidentaux et des Américains en
particulier bon voilà l'Ukraine n'existe
pas donc l'objectif territorial
dépend de la des capacités de l'armée
russe à accomplir les rêves de son du
président russe ils veulent nous
détruire ils veulent faire d'un conflit
local d'un conflit global avec toujours
cette menace sans la préciser nous
réagirons il accuse finalement
l'Occident de mener une guerre contre la
Russie
ah oui ça c'est le discours depuis le
début il n'y a pas grand chose de
nouveau là dedans il n'y a pas eu de
menaces même implicite de recours à
l'arme nucléaire en fin du mois
il a été fait beaucoup il a été plus
explicite dans le passé mais il faut
quand même souligner que Vladimir
Poutine a l'attitude d'un plutôt d'un
vainqueur
il n'est pas
déchaîné il n'est pas tendu il est
plutôt il me paraît plutôt à l'aise et
il tient un discours de quelqu'un qui
est absolument certain de ne pas pouvoir
perdre cette guerre d'ailleurs il a dit
on ne peut pas défaire la Russie sur le
champ de bataille oui c'est ça il dit
nous sommes imbattable sur le terrain il
le savent alors il nous attaque sur les
valeurs l'influence l'information oui il
va expliquer qu'il y avait une guerre
sur trois fronts militaires économique
et informationnel les
occidentaux on a autant pour lui c'est à
dire qu'effectivement on estime que la
guerre
déclenchée par
il faut savoir enfin
c'est un lieu commun que de dire que la
guerre est généralement une prophétie
auto-réalisatrice mais en l'espèce c'est
très frappant parce qu'à force de
répéter que à force de répéter que la
Russie est victime d'une guerre que lui
a déclaré l'OTAN et qu'elle n'est pas
vraiment en guerre contre les Ukrainiens
mais plutôt contre les Occidentaux
qui sont aux portes de la Russie et qui
menacent la Russie évidemment vous
finissez par vous encourage enfin
quand les
Occidentaux se mettent à aider les les
Ukrainiens ils accomplissent votre
prophétie bien sûr donc en ce sens là
aussi bien l'aide militaire ou
économique des Occidentaux à l'Ukraine
mais un événement comme la visite de Joe
Biden hier à Kiev s'inscrit parfaitement
bonne raison si vous voulez à Vladimir
Poutine dans sa propre rhétorique on
peut pas le contredire non et plus la
guerre avance moins plus la prophétie
s'auto réalise la lumière Poutine qui
s'était exprimée près d'une demi-heure
sur la situation intérieure en Russie
puisque c'est l'objectif de ce discours
traditionnel qui a lieu normalement tous
les ans se dit c'est vraiment le petit
père du peuple russe si c'est tout de
l'éducation des ponts des rivières
non non dans cette attitude là en France
aussi on parle du président qui s'occupe
de tout mais oui oui
il nous le rappelle il parlait donc de
la situation intérieure aussi des
entrain de revenir sur cette opération
militaire spéciale c'est le terme
courant qui n'est pas employé le enfin
qu'il est gardé ce cette expression
parce que en fait il décrit vraiment une
guerre totale mais il continue à
l'appeler opération militaire spéciale
on écoute à nouveau Vladimir Poutine
semble s'approcher de la fin du discours
cocktail je voudrais répéter
le traité mais avant
de revenir à ce sujet nous devons
comprendre la position de la France et
la de la Grande Bretagne
nous devons tenir compte de leurs
arsenaux stratégiques c'est-à-dire le la
capacité totale de frappe de l'Alliance
atlantique
par leurs actions et ils se sont
[Musique]
participer dans ce processus mais il ne
faut pas mentir nous connaissons très
bien de quoi il s'agit on sait que
pour certains arsenaux nucléaires les
délais de service arrivent à échéance et
nous savons qu'à Washington certains
pensent à faire des essais naturels
de
différentes armements
le ministère de la Défense russe et
rosatum doivent permettre aux
arsenaux russes d'être également testé
c'est les États-Unis testent l'harmonie
nucléaire nous aussi nous allons tester
l'arme nucléaire personne ne doit avoir
d'illusions le
la parité stratégique globale ne peut
pas être mise en cause
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui
nous sommes à une étape difficile nous
sommes sur un chemin difficile et mais
nous sommes tous ensemble
et cela ne pouvait pas être autrement
parce que nous prenons l'exemple sur nos
grands ancêtres c'est ce sont des
exemples qui sont transmis dans
l'histoire et nous allons toujours de
l'avant grâce à notre volonté grâce à
notre amour de la patrie et cette
cohésion depuis le début de l'opération
militaire spéciale a déjà été démontré
des centaines de représentants de
différents peuples constituants notre
nation sont venues dans les bureaux de
conscription et se sont portés
volontaires pour porter pour participer
au combat et les combattants de
différentes régions toutes les régions
de notre
y participent au combat il prit il prit
dans leur langue nationale
mais il prit pour notre patrie
[Musique]
les gens les soutiennent
soutiennent nos combattants
les gens ne veulent pas
rester à côté tout le monde est concerné
et les gens envoient au front les
médicaments des différentes choses pour
aider
nos combattants il y a des lettres des
élèves des écoles notamment et je sais
que ça fait chaud au cœur à nos
militaires parce qu'il les prennent et
ils emportent avec eux dans le combat
parce que c'est
sincère c'est pur ce sont des
différentes paroles des enfants et nos
militaires savent pourquoi ils
combattent pour les militaires et leurs
familles c'est très important également
de sentir
les soins en couleur portent les
volontaires
toutes les personnes qui sont allées
dans les zones de combat pour aider
notamment les civils il y a des
personnes qui travaillent aussi dans des
centres de réfugiés dans les hôpitaux
militaires sur la ligne de front c'est
Jean risque leur vie ils sauvent les
vies des autres nous avons une
initiative tout pour la victoire 5
milliards de roubles ont été collectés
c'est important de continuer à soutenir
nos militaires c'est très important en
ce qui concerne les entreprises mais
nous sommes particulièrement touchés et
inspirés
quand il y a des personnes
de revenus modestes qui également verse
de l'argent dans ces fonds
pour soutenir
les militaires et les réfugiés dans les
zones de combat je voudrais vous
remercier pour votre soutien sincère et
pour votre cohésion votre aide et
inestimable
[Applaudissements]
et la Russie va répondre à tous les
défis parce que nous sommes un seul
grand pays nous sommes un grand et seul
peuple
et nous avons confiance en nos forces la
vérité et de notre côté
je vous remercie
[Musique]
je pense qu'elle est plus formelle que
que
réellement significatif d'abord je crois
que les le dialogue sur ces sur ces
sujets étaient déjà largement suspendu
depuis depuis un an
même si en fait ces accords doivent être
renouvelés prochainement et les Russes
et les Américains juste après l'élection
de Joe Biden avait convenu dans
prolonger la durée le temps de pouvoir
les renégocier bon c'est cette
renégociation qui qui est qui est mise à
mal c'est pas très surprenant dans la
mesure où on est dans un contexte un
président russe qui dit qui qu'il était
en guerre contre l'Occident
il y a une certaine logique je dirais
militaire à à ne pas à interrompre à
suspendre les négociations de réduction
des arsenaux ce qui m'intéresse
davantage c'est la formule
sur les tests
les armes nucléaire qu'il une attention
qu'il prête aux Américains et dont il
dit dont il prend prétexte pour dire que
nous aussi russe on va devoir tester nos
armes nucléaires alors c'est pas très
clair est-ce que c'est si des uns le si
des Américains le font on le fera aussi
ou bien est-ce que on va sortir une
bombe nucléaire dans un endroit un peu
désert juste pour montrer que ça marche
mais on appellera ça un test enfin vous
savez ça peut être une une version un
peu nord-coréenne oui c'est ça
continuent à tester les armes nucléaires
il y a un moratoire sur les tests
nucléaires qui s'appliquent dans le
monde entier que la Russie respecte
d'ailleurs donc non non on a fini ces
petits jeux dans les atolls du Pacifique
ou les déserts d'Afrique il y a il y a
quelques décennies maintenant donc les
les experts enfin les ingénieurs
nucléaires y compris mil
[Musique]
ils ont les Occidentaux ont menti de
manière
éhontée et ont été scandaleuses et nous
nous disons la vérité nous nous tenons
notre parole nous mentons à personne et
nous nous soutenons dans les périodes
difficiles donc la vertu et uniquement
du camp du côté russe c'est clair et net
pour Vladimir Poutine ça doit être clair
et net pour tous ceux qui s'inscrivent
dans son sillage
voilà même si il ouvre une porte à ceux
qui ont qui ont fui le pays à la faveur
de la guerre en leur disant mais vous
allez vous allez rester comme ça à toute
votre vie en dépit de l'argent que vous
pourrez accumuler vous serez des
citoyens de seconde
catégorie donc revenez en Russie et
aider la patrie
d'expliquer Nicolas Barot tout à l'heure
contre les oligarques russes
enfin c'était plus un mépris qu'une
menace
on ne votre sort ne nous fait pas
pleurer en Russie en fait il aimait
prise et il tient vraiment ou c'est un
discours populiste parce qu'il a besoin
de ses puissances financière ou pas
vraiment où ça de toute façon
comme Poutine a très bien expliqué les
avoir de ces gens-là sont bloqués en
accident donc qu'il se trouve
physiquement en Russie ou qu'il soit
dans leur villa de
la Côte d'Azur à terme ils sont ils ont
quand même des problèmes pour profiter
de leur ressources en Occident toujours
donc je pense qu'il y a un grand mépris
de la part de Poutine et il tient
surtout à ce que le peuple les méprises
avec lui
et voilà la réalité ça se sont il a
accusé ces gens de spolier l'économie
russe d'avoir profité en
d'ailleurs profiter du système
économique mis en place ce qu'il a
appelé très joliment une parenthèse Phil
graphique et la parenthèse philosophique
consistait à dire vous vous souvenez à
la fin de l'ère soviétique on a eu des
tas de conseillers occidentaux et en
fait sont eux qui ont façonné notre
économie pour qu'elle soit complètement
dépendante d'eux et qu'elle ne soit
bonne qu'à fournir des matières
premières et donc ça c'est un discours
qui a été applaudi d'ailleurs parce que
lui est en train de refaçonner
complètement l'économie russe sur le
long terme pour en faire un pays
sinon autosuffisant du moins totalement
indépendant de des économies
occidentales il y a une élection en 2024
en Russie ça c'était l'une des questions
il l'a dit ils sont présidentielle il
affirme les droits et libertés des
citoyens sont inviolables ils sont
garantis par la Constitution nous ne
reculerons pas devant ceci je tiens à
souligner que les élections aux
autorités locales et régionales de cette
année et les élections présidentielles
de 2024 se tiendront dans le strict
respect de la loi il y a des gens en
Russie qui doutent de ça
le peuple russe est entièrement derrière
Vladimir Poutine c'est toujours
difficile de cerner l'opinion du peuple
russe oui bien sûr c'est difficile de
cerner l'opinion et peuple russe parce
que il n'y a pas vraiment de liberté et
de penser si vous êtes à opposant
déclaré et bien vous êtes au goulag
comme navani ou bien si vous êtes un
adversaire jugé gênant vous êtes abattu
comme l'ont été d'anciens oligares
sous les murailles même du Kremlin donc
et on ne parle pas de ceux qui ont été
empoisonnés à Londres et donc c'est un
régime dictatorial en tout cas
autoritaire incarnée par une seule
personne à laquelle vous ne pouvez pas
vous opposer donc
il faut pas s'étonner que que
tout le discours de Vladimir Poutine
soit avec moi ou contre moi si vous
n'êtes pas avec moi vous êtes contre moi
dernière question Philippe il a agité le
sentiment patriotique historique du
peuple russe il se réfère à cette grande
histoire et proche de l'URSS même si
c'est peut-être un sentiment douloureux
pour les pour les Russes il s'y réfère
régulièrement à la puissance de cette
Russie là oui en fait la vraie référence
mobilisatrice c'est celle de la grande
guerre patriotique c'est-à-dire c'est le
nom qu'on donne en Russie à la Seconde
Guerre mondiale
mais il n'y a fait que des allusions
assez assez légère je trouve aujourd'hui
pourquoi sans doute parce que
cette notion porte avec elle le le
souvenir de 27 millions de morts et que
on en est pas là loin et loin sans faute
et heureusement
avec cette guerre en Ukraine qu'on n'est
pas encore
dans un conflit généralisé avec les
Occidentaux même s'il le présente comme
tel il n'y a pas un soldat
occidental
engagé par les États dans les rangs de
l'Ukraine donc
la force de la grande guerre patriotique
et du patriotisme historique russe elle
est mobilisatrice mais jusqu'à un
certain point et j'ai trouvé encore une
fois
Poutine compte tenu des circonstances
relativement décontractées dans son
expression
relativement à l'aise
adoptant la posture de quelqu'un qui
n'est pas inquiet qui est absolument
certain de la victoire qui
vit dans un monde
alors il en reconnaît les difficultés
mais disent un moment historique et en
fait il faut en profiter
quand il a parlé des sanctions il a dit
la situation change pour le mieux c'est
à dire oui tout ce qui nous est imposé
par les Occidentaux nous permet de nous
adapter et en fait et cette guerre nous
permet de nous retrouver face à
nous-mêmes entre guillemets
les Russes face à eux-mêmes et de
façonner le la Russie dont rêve Vladimir
Poutine après ce discours en attendant
un discours important
près d'un an après le début de cette
guerre quand retenir est-ce que ça
change quelque chose pas vraiment
finalement on va continuer comme ça et
ça dépend à quoi vous voulez que ça
change quelque chose ça ne change rien
ça ne change rien évidemment à au cours
de la guerre en
Ukraine
sachant ça confirme mais on le savait
déjà que la Russie est engagée dans un
quelque chose de long terme de très long
terme à la fois militairement mais bien
bien au-delà dans son adaptation
intérieure à la nouvelle donne
internationale c'est-à-dire qu'en fait
ce que décrit Poutine
c'est le il dresse le constat de décès
de l'ordre international ordre entre
guillemets
hérité de la deuxième guerre mondiale
dominée par les occidentaux il faut bien
l'admettre
rejeter par la Russie mais pas seulement
rejeté aussi par la Chine rejetait aussi
de manière de manière moins radicale
par beaucoup de pays qui veulent rester
neutres dans dans ce conflit et il a
essayé de leur parler aux non alignés
il a parlé de projet d'infrastructure
jusqu'à Kazakhstan jusqu'en Chine etc
donc ce qui est frappant c'est ce
constat de de trépas si vous voulez de
l'ordre entre guillemets encore une fois
international hérité de la deuxième
guerre mondiale et le la Russie qui
s'engage sur le long terme pour se
refassonner dans un univers un
environnement complètement différent ou
on oublie les Occidentaux qui veulent
qui sont contre nous par principe contre
nos valeurs contre notre culture contre
notre religion etc etc et on ne s'appuie
que sur nos amis et sur nos propres
forces merci beaucoup Philippe Gely
merci de nous avoir éclairé directeur de
la rédaction du Figaro en charge de
l'international
merci à tous de nous avoir suivis sur le
Figaro.fr sur Youtube les meilleurs
extraits et bien vous pouvez les
retrouver sur le Figaro live les
meilleurs extraits en tout cas les
phrases fortes à retenir de ce discours
de Vladimir Poutine excellente
après-midi excellente journée sur le
figure live